We've been talking about,
uh,
oxidation and reduction.
And today we're going to talk about a very special kind of oxidation by,
uh,
Iota Casad,
a pariah date.
That is to say,
uh,
variety cleavage,
the carbon wheel with an alcohol.
Then let's try that.
Uh,
carbon deal with two alcohol molecules,
but the chromium,
which is double bonded to three oxygens and don't think about the chromium just
for the terms of the analog.
Just think of as thinking,
I suppose that was a carbonyl group instead of Idaho Bondos suppose it was c
double bond o what reaction do you get?
Yeah,
yeah.
Pardon me.
[inaudible] you could imagine.
Yes.
Effication of an acid with an ester.
But I said not suppose it's not it.
Suppose that we're a carbonyl group.
C double bond o no,
h on the group up at top.
What reaction do you get between a ketone yet?
Matt Aquis
towel.
Right.
So you get a reaction.
It's just like that.
Tell forums.
Right.
And now we have a thing that's a little bit like ozone.
Okay.
Because this sort of sort of key towel can unzip.
Right?
That's what reminds you a little bit of ozone,
that kind of thing.
Okay.
So it can come apart that way.
Right?
And notice that's what what's happened is that the dial has become to carbon
eels.
And of course that's an oxidation.
The eidon started an oxidation state seven,
right?
Seven bonds to oxygen and it ended in five,
So the I had and has reduced and at the same time the carbon is oxidized.
It's plus one here and it's plus two over here,
right?
And two of them get oxidized.
Two carbons get oxidized.
Okay.
Now this might remind you of have this reaction where you get to carbon IOLs.
And what uh,
what reaction is that?
What reagent we'll do that.
That's ozone.
Alright.
What reagent does it oh zone.
So it's nice to think of it about
when do you have a certain functional group you want to get?
What reaction will lead to it?
So there's one that will lead to that.
We could also think what reaction would come back from to ketones to give a dial
with a carbon carbon bond in between.
That's a more exotic reaction.
Does anybody remember that one?
That's the pinnacle reduction,
right?
That we talked about were metals,
give electrons to the ketones,
the radicals couple.
And then you,
you have to old minuses that get hydrogens on them.
So That's the pinnacle reduction that we mentioned.
And then you might wonder if there's a reaction that does that right.
And we'll see an indirect version of that later in this lecture.
That's the video reaction,
which is familiar or it involves the vedic reaction,
which is a familiar to you from lab.
So periodic acid,
cleavage of carbohydrates as a diagnostic tool.
This is a useful reaction.
It actually,
it actually used to prepare compounds,
but it also was historically important in finding out the ring size of,
uh,
of sugars that we talked about earlier as a problem.
Remember nowadays you do that kind of thing by Nmr,
but in the early days you had to do chemical transformations to known compounds
in order to figure out what something was,
right?
So if you have a dial as we just showed,
you could react it with periodic acid and get to aldehydes in particular for
this one.
Formaldehyde.
Okay.
So remember what,
what sugars are a bunch of carbons in a row?
Their carbohydrates.
So it's carbon hydrate.
Ooh,
h and then the carbons linked together and one end to see h two o h typically.
And the other end is an Aldehyde or the carbon eel.
Could be other positions down the chain.
Okay,
but how do you figure out what they are?
Okay.
Suppose you had three in a row and did periodic acid.
Okay,
so you,
you react with one of them and get the formaldehyde out from the end.
But from the bottom part there you get another Aldehyde and Ooh.
And that reacts again with per ionic acid.
Now why?
Because remember,
the aldehydes form hydrates.
So that's their equivalent in water to alcohols.
So now we have a dial again and per ionic asset oxidizes and cleaves such dials,
right?
So from this reaction,
then you get to formaldehyde molecules and the one in the middle,
which had only one hydrogen on the carbon,
gives formic acid.
Okay?
So formaldehyde arises from the primary alcohols at the end of the chain and
formic acid from the ones in the middle of the chain that have just an h on
them.
And incidentally,
I've taken these slides from lectures given in the course last year by Professor
Ziegler cause he had nicely animated them already.
Uh,
so here's that reaction we just talked about.
Now suppose we had an Aldehyde at the end of the chain and we did this right now
the one now the one,
not only the one in the middle of the chain has only one h on it,
but the one at the top has only one age.
So from that,
when you get a formaldehyde and two,
four make acids,
right?
Or if the carbon eel,
we're in the middle of the chain,
you're going to get to four.
Uh,
you gotta get formaldehyde and the,
and the,
uh,
acid in the middle.
But that acid in the middle itself can hydrate and Lou and be oxidized and give
CO2.
So from this one,
we get to a Aldehyde to formaldehydes and a co two molecule,
right?
So now we could go down and see what groups were that our includes an adjacent
h,
right?
Uh,
and what,
which products you'd get from formaldehyde,
formic acid and carbon dioxide.
So that just summarizes what we just looked at.
Now Suppose you had glucose right now the top would give formic acid,
the next company and formic acid for me,
Casad formic acid,
formic acid at the bottom would be formaldehyde.
Cause there were two H's on it,
right?
If you had mannitol,
a reduced form related to glucose,
then the top would be formaldehyde to ages and acid,
acid,
and at the bottom would be formaldehyde.
So you see the ratio of these various well known products.
You get out,
tell you something about what the structure of the of the uh,
sugar was.
Or if you had fructose,
which has a ketone in it,
you'd get formaldehyde in the top CEO two now from the one that has no hydrogens
at all.
Acid acid,
acid,
a formaldehyde.
And you can also apply it to the question of the key towels that are formed when
you form a ring.
So I remember we spoke before about this key towel being a protecting group,
both for the Aldehyde that was formerly here and that's it's oxygen.
And for the alcohol that was here.
Okay,
now we talked about the problem of determining the ring size.
Think what would happen with this with Hii oh four.
So it would cleave those two bonds where there are adjacent ohs,
right?
Visitable.
Those are the only places where they're adjacent.
Ohs.
So we'd give formic acid.
There was one h on that central carbon and aldehydes on the end.
And now if you treated that with acid and heat,
then you'd open up the,
the key towel,
right?
Key towels could be opened by acid.
Incidentally,
uh,
people don't typically notice the necessity for heat in this,
but it must require heat because if you can get that product,
which hasn't opened,
the key towel in the first reaction,
which has done at room temperature for a day per iot acid is a strong acid,
right?
So here's water and it's done in water.
So it's water with an acid.
Ketalysis,
you'd think it would take the key towel apart.
But in fact,
taking the key talent apart requires some heat.
So that's done in the second step.
And then you,
uh,
you get the,
the Aldehyde taken apart.
So the pieces you get are from the piece up here.
Uh,
you get,
uh,
Ooh,
and Aldehyde.
So you get Douglas or Aldehyde,
uh,
from the piece over here.
You get Aldehyde and Aldehyde again and find that of course there's methanol
that came along because it was a,
because it was,
uh,
the,
key dal involving that alcohol.
So by telling what the products are,
you can tell what the ring size was.
Now here's the problem for you to think about.
Suppose you could imagine these key towels being formed with other,
instead of this,
instead of this ooh being the one that's involved to make a six membered ring,
it could have been this Oah and made a five membered ring.
Or in principle,
this one that made a four or that one that made a seven membered ring.
I'd like you to make a table that shows what the products would have been from
[inaudible] oxidation of those others to see whether in fact you can prove what
the ring size was by what products come out from this.
This was,
this,
a reaction was,
was developed in 1928 and applied for that purpose,
that analytical purpose.
Okay,
so that's oxidation.
Now we're going to talk about a little bit of a,
of reduction and in particular about making,
uh,
about synthesizing alcohols and the idea of retro synthesis a little bit,
which is,
uh,
you look at the product,
usually it's a product you want to have and you're trying to figure out what
starting materials and reagents would have given it.
So really you're working backwards rather than forwards in a synthesis.
So analyze in such problems as called retro synthesis.
And we'll engage in a little bit of this here.
Uh,
using a problem that occurs in the Jones Textbook.
Okay,
so here's an alcohol we want to get.
We want to put our on a,
on an alcohol that already has two methyls right now we can start with acetone
there,
the two methyls and now we have to put the R on.
Now what kind of are do we need in order to attack a carbon eel?
What will attack a carbon eel to make a carbon carbon bond for our,
what form of our will we use?
For example,
could you use at how kill haylight our cl,
would that be something that would react in order to give this product?
What is it that will react with the car video?
What makes a carbon eel reactive?
Roy,
you need a nucleophile.
So you need a carbon that has a high homo on it.
Can you think of any such things?
Where do you get a high home?
We'll want a carbon from a grid yar reaction.
Where,
or I'll kill lithium,
something where our is attached to a metal ion,
so it'll be our minus.
Okay.
So you have are with a metal,
like a,
a Grinny are reagent or an owl kill lithium,
right?
You do this reaction.
Then of course you can,
uh,
those electrons can be used to form of bond to the metal and you get that
intermediate.
And in fact,
as we've already discussed,
it's not so obvious what the order of those additions are.
The are heading to carbon in the metal ahead into oxygen.
It could be either first or in fact,
probably both at the same time.
Uh,
so at anyhow we can,
we can make that new carbon carbon bond and then treat the salt,
the Oh minus and plus with h plus and get the alcohol.
So there's a simple synthesis.
Now suppose we wanted to put an h instead of an are,
what form of h do we need?
Can we do this with an acid for example?
H plus.
Is that going to be a good idea?
Megan?
What?
What type of reagent,
what kind of age would attack the carbon eel?
What makes the carving?
He overreacted
low.
Lubo so you need an h with a High Hobo.
How about Proton?
Protons have no electronics at all.
So what form of HD you need h minus.
Where are you going to get h?
Minus?
Where did you get r minus
our metal art metal.
So what do we need now?
H metal.
Okay,
so this is going to be a hydride reduction.
Okay.
So we have h with a metal doing exactly the same thing we showed above,
except it's h minus instead of our mind is doing the trick and we get it from
something like h attached to aluminum with a minus charge on the aluminum,
which means it's really going to be a high homo or h attached to Boron with a
minus charge on it.
So those reagents are lithium aluminum hydride sodium borohydride,
which can reduce a,
an alcohol to put the h on there.
Okay.
And we also talked about the biological equivalent of these hydride donors,
which is a n a d h where the unshared pair on the nitrogen can get into the act
forming an aromatic system and losing h minus,
which can go onto the carbon eel a group.
Okay.
So we have,
uh,
our minus or h minus as ways to attack carbon yield groups.
Now let's look a little bit at the synthetic versatility of Greeny,
our reagents.
So the,
here's a problem to suggest high yields syntheses,
where the carbons come only from alcohol's with no more than three carbons.
And,
but you can use any other reagent.
Now,
these are very artificial.
These are not a problem you'd be faced with in the laboratory because almost
all,
many of these you could buy,
not all of them,
but many of them you could buy cheaper than you could make them,
right?
But in a way of thinking about how you do syntheses and an elementary way,
this is a good exercise and it's,
as I've mentioned here,
you can find that problem in,
in,
uh,
the Jones Textbook.
So let's think first about the first molecule in this list.
Now,
what's the,
what problem do we face in making this from alcohols with no more than three
carbons,
therefore carbons in it?
So we've got to make a carbon carbon bond somehow.
So,
uh,
let's think about what carbon carbon bonds we might make.
We could make the first carbon carbon bond nearest doh or the next one or the
next one,
right?
There are three that we could make.
And let's see how we would go about that.
Okay.
First,
let's try to make the one adjacent to the age.
So we need to have two carbons that will react with one another.
One a high homo,
the other,
the low Lumo that will establish that bond.
Okay,
so we did a nucleophile,
a high homo,
and an electrifying the low Lumo.
So what will the nucleophile be?
Anybody got an idea?
Yeah,
it could be either the piece on the left or the piece on the right.
If the nucleophile,
if the electro file where the piece on the left,
the three carbon,
what kind of,
what kind of molecule would you do use?
If it were three carbons and you want it to be attacked by a high homo,
right?
A Halon would do it right.
The loads.
The sigma star of I'll kill haylight would do that.
Okay.
Now suppose you wanted it to be the high homo,
then what would you do?
Megan,
you just told us about that.
Suppose you wanted our to be a high homo.
You'd use a metal now feel metal.
Okay.
Now,
how about the electro file on the right?
Uh,
here's a great example of a use the low Lubo of carbon eel.
So now what we want on the,
on the left is the high homo.
We want the Al Kill metal,
but we can,
but we can only start from alcohols.
In fact,
we can't even start with this because that's a carbon that goes into the
product.
We have to start from an alcohol.
So how are we going to make that from an alcohol?
How is it related to an alcohol to eight,
which has an h on the car.
So we get an h on the carbon h on here.
That would be an alcohol.
Methanol.
What kind of reagent do we need to get from the alcohol to this?
Yeah,
it's an oxidation.
Is that a reduction?
Is it needed to remove two hydrogens?
It's an oxidation.
There's a problem though because the oxidizing agents that oxidize alcohol's
also react with aldehydes.
If you have any water,
their water,
we'll add,
make the Aldehyde into a dial,
right?
And then that will react that we'll get oxidized by the reagent.
How do you avoid that?
We've talked about this last time.
You don't have any water there,
right?
So we talked about that last time period end IOM chloro chromate done in
methylene chloride solvent.
So there's no water there.
Can do that trick.
So we have the electric file.
Now we need the nucleophile.
We need a c three group with a metal on it,
but we can only start with an alcohol.
So if we had normal propyl Grinny our reagent,
that would do the trick.
Where do you get a grin?
Yard reagent from our MTBR.
What's the starting material?
Okay,
so you guys need to go through this to get a little drill under your belts.
Okay.
Did you get,
you get Grinny our reagents from Al Kill Haylight ads.
Okay,
so we could get it from,
we get our Mtbr from magnesium and Al [inaudible] and Al [inaudible] Bromide.
But where do we get the [inaudible] bromide?
We could only the,
the rules of the game have a starting with alcohol.
Yeah.
Amy,
can you hear three PBR.
Three on the alcohol,
right.
So we got it.
Okay,
so we could make that first one.
Now how about the second one?
Now we need a,
we need an electro file in a nucleophile the electro file.
Now on the left could be the ethyl magnesium bromide,
just two carbons.
And we would make it the same way here.
Uh,
starting with ethanol instead of propanol.
So that one's okay.
Now what will the group on the right B,
we want to be able to attack this carbon and end up with Oah on the adjacent
carbon.
Right now you haven't done a lot of problems like this,
but you need to think them through and whatever textbook you're using,
you'll find problems of this sort.
So try some of them.
But W we talked about such a reaction,
which is an EFP oxide.
Remember the strange rings could be attacked by a nucleophile the open here,
right?
But w a t t to form this ring where you attack this carbon in the oak comes away
as a leaving group.
Protonated now,
uh,
where do we get that from?
Where does it have Parkside come from?
We have to start with an alcohol.
Any reactions that give EFP oxides.
Okay.
Hey,
come by adding oxygen to an alkene.
Okay.
Anybody remember the reagents at the land and oxygen?
What as the,
that something say good odds Liam?
Uh,
no.
The,
the,
the osmium tetroxide takes an alkene and puts two o's on it,
right?
That'll put two o's.
We want to just put one over in the middle and you'll kick yourself when I oh
yeah,
Chris,
the CEO.
I think we do it,
but you need something else.
You can add cl and o h and then remove hcl.
That was one way of doing it.
There's another way where you do it in one step.
EPDA MCP,
VA Mehta,
chloro per benzoic acid.
Or remember that cyclic butterflied mechanism that transfer the oxygen from the
proxy acid.
Okay?
So we got that,
but now we need the owl cane,
but we only have available alcohols,
but that's a trivial one.
Just dehydrated alcohol or,
or dehydrate and Al Bromide,
right?
So you treat it with strong base and remove HBR and you've got things.
Okay,
so we've got that.
We could do that one,
uh,
with heat and Naoh.
Okay.
Now,
how about the bottom one?
That one is quite a problem.
The problem is that you could have methyl Grinny are,
but what are you going to attack?
Because if you had a four membered ring here with oxygen,
it wouldn't,
it wouldn't open.
It's not strange like the three membered ring would be,
and you,
if you try to make the nucleophile be on the left,
that top right carbon being in an eye on,
and this one being say Formaldehyde,
then you have the problem that you have two oh eight,
you'd get an Oah here,
right?
And that's a problem because you have to get rid of just one of the two Oh ages
or uh,
or you would have to have a grin yar reagent or something like here.
And that would react with its own age.
Now you could imagine complicated schemes where you use protecting groups and
stuff like that.
So it's conceivable,
but it's hard work because this is not a particularly good carbon to be,
to be reactive.
The,
you could have,
if so,
it's not an an activated position.
This one was in a position where it could have been attached to that oxygen.
This one was in a position that was a carbonyl,
but this one has no special virtues that makes it reactive.
So,
so that one is a tough one to make.
Okay,
now let's think about the second one.
now we,
let's try to make that bond.
For example,
right now we need a nucleophile and electrified.
Does anybody have an idea of what the low Lumo is that could be attacked?
In order to make that red bond,
you have an idea.
We want to make this carbon carbon bond and one of the two carbons has to be a
high homo and the other and unusually low Lumo.
And notice incidentally that this one that's a need that needs to be one of them
is has an oxygen next door.
Carbon carbon double bond with.
Oh right.
So then what would you use on the right?
Um,
RCL RCL
is,
is like our plus,
right?
You want our minus,
you want a high homo,
not the low luma,
not sigma star.
What would you use?
That was a battle,
right?
Okay.
So we needed a nucleophile and electrify all,
we use the three carbons on the right,
right as a,
as a Greenie our reagent.
And now we need that Aldehyde,
right?
That for Carbon Aldehyde,
we can only start with three carbon things.
So we can't oxidize one of the things they give us and make that Aldehyde.
How are we going to make that four Carbon Aldehyde?
Any ideas?
Okay.
You don't have to look far,
Linda,
do you have an idea?
You need
four carbons that terminate in oxygen,
double Bondo.
And you can only start with three carbons.
Can you think of any way of making four carbons?
When you start with,
with three or less,
that was the first problem.
So you've already made this.
Can you think of any way of making the Aldehyde?
How do you go from the alcohol to the Aldehyde?
What do you need to do?
You need to remove two H's,
right?
It's an oxidation.
So think only of oxidizing agents.
Can you think of any oxidizing agent that changes in alcohol to an Aldehyde
pcs?
So that's just the art too.
Uh,
Vr tube to do it right,
but you're going to have problems depending on how you do it,
of over oxidation.
The aldehydes can go on to acids.
VCC,
the same one we used on the last slide.
So you treat that one at PCC and in the,
uh,
methylene chloride solvent.
You got that Aldehyde.
So we've solved the second one,
PCC and methylene chloride.
Now.
So the next one that they suggest you try to make is this one.
Now suppose you wanted to make that bond.
Can you think of any way of doing it,
Ellen?
What's going to be the nucleophile?
Yeah,
what's the are going to be,
is it on the right or the left?
The one we're ready.
It's going to be the,
the,
our metal that we're going to deal with.
Are we,
is it going to be this carbon or this carbon?
Okay.
The bottom right at the top left carbon.
What's the top left carbon going to be in order to make that wrong?
Amy and I'll be,
uh,
another legacy.
Don't Bondo.
So you know,
Bondo.
This,
when we see the old next to the carbon,
we think Aldehyde is,
that's,
that's gotta be the Lumo that gets attacked.
And the Hobo Ella,
the one on the right's going to be a graveyard.
But this time instead of an propal,
it's ice or pro ball.
And this is the Aldehyde.
We need any way of getting that Aldehyde Ella?
Yeah,
that's the same way.
It's the same one to five,
right?
So we got that one.
Okay.
Now how about this one?
Any ideas for that?
So let's make that bond.
Okay.
So what gets attacked on the left?
Amy,
you had help us again.
Well,
it would be the top where the second one,
how many carbons on the left?
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
We can only start with three carbon alcohols.
So could you make the second product and then there's some kind of at the second
problem.
The second product has the seven with like with an alcohol in the middle.
So what do you do?
You need a ketone in the middle.
You've made the alcohol,
you need the Ketone,
so you have to oxidize it.
So you could use the same reagent again,
but you don't need to worry because it's a ketone this time.
So you're not so worried about over oxidation.
So you could use one of those chromate things that we talked about or,
or borough mean or anything.
And on the right,
it's just the,
and propyl again,
we've already made that.
Okay,
so we got that one made.
What about if we wanted to make the next bond,
the,
the vertical bond instead?
Oh,
I didn't show it here.
Well,
what if,
what if we needed to make the vertical bond?
It's the same thing,
right?
The things symmetrical.
It has three SL,
three propyl groups on there.
Okay,
so here's another one.
How are we gonna make this one?
Well,
we could make that bond.
Anybody see how to do that?
Mary,
what are we going to use on the right?
Same one here.
I started to say,
one is here.
I said approachable.
Okay.
And what's on the left?
We're going to oxidize the oxygen,
right?
And it's going to be the same one,
That's seven carbon.
So we got that one.
And now finally,
uh,
how about if we wanted to make that one instead,
then what would the grin Yar,
reagent B,
it would be in propyl instead of ice appropriate.
And what would the Ketone B it would be this?
And where would we get that
by oxidizing this one?
Right?
Okay.
And finally,
this one,
now we could imagine making this bond or making this bond or making this bond,
and we have the means to do all these things now,
but one wonders,
is there a preferred order?
Is One way of doing this better than the others?
Right?
And in this case,
I suspect that they're all about the same.
Uh,
it might come down to what's cheap and available and so on,
which alcohols are cheaper.
And in fact,
of course you would never do this because simple things like this,
you would,
you wouldn't start from the alcohol,
you'd buy the bromide or something like that.
But when you talk about versatility of Grinny are agents,
there are other things they could do to,
for example,
if you try to make the dye ice of propyl methyl version of the carbonyl here,
right?
To make this one.
You find that you can,
that you do first make the salt,
then treat it with acid.
You get that alcohol and it's 95% yield.
Great.
Now suppose you wanted to use t butyl instead of methyl,
right?
So you want to get that one.
So you try that reaction and you get 0% yield of that.
The product is this.
So what was it that added to the carbon eel?
It wasn't the t butyl an eye on what an ion was it?
What did the addition,
it was hydride but where did the hydride come from?
Okay,
so it was a reduction by h minus or the equivalent of h minus,
right?
What you had was the t butyl grin yard.
Now what problem did t beautiful Grin Yar have in trying to form this alcohol?
Yeah,
Cassie spherically hindered the carbon.
Can't get close to the carbon,
but a hydrogen can get close to the harbor,
right?
That Beta hydrogen can get close to the carbon.
So now we can do this,
right?
And you'll see that the,
that,
that the,
the carbon part that was t butyl loses magnesium and loses age to become the
alkene and the,
and the other product then is that 65% yield alcohol.
And this reminds you this hydrogen transfer from t butyl,
although it's happening here in the context of an anti and it reminds you of two
t butyl radicals having trouble for me in the carbon carbon bond and
transferring a hydrogen atom instead for the same reason,
okay?
To avoid steric hindrance.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
if you use t butyl ch two magnesium bromide,
then you don't have to worry about this hydride transfer because it has ch two
in this position and three methyls attached to that carbon.
There is no hydrogen in the Beta position.
So it looks like we're home free here,
but you only get a 4% yield of the Grin Yard,
right?
Cause it's still sterically hindered.
What you get instead is reduction of the,
of the,
uh,
of the uh,
or,
or protonation pardon me,
of the t butyl of the,
uh,
of the uh,
neopentyl group.
Right?
So remember that the ketone itself has alpha hydrogens.
So you can form enal h you can give up a proton from those.
So this,
this thing which is a nucleophile is also a strong base and can take that off.
And you get that one,
uh,
easily plus the Eataly,
which lost the Proton.
But then when you work it up with acid,
you've protonated again.
So the ketone gets recovered it 90% of it and the,
and,
and the,
uh,
your,
carefully made Grinny our reagent just becomes a hydrocarbon.
No use there.
Okay?
So those are other things that can happen with Grinny our reagents.
And that same thing incidentally can happen here because this one also this,
the Alpha hydrogen was president here and this one was a strong base.
And in fact,
35% of that one was that plus the,
uh,
starting Keto.
And after you put the Proton back on,
okay?
Uh,
now,
uh,
this,
if you try to make this bond as we just,
uh,
you could make it,
with notice the difference this time is that it's ice appropriately instead of t
butyl group here,
right?
So you could try doing this,
Uh,
so that has an h Beta and steric hindrance.
So there's the risk that it would give reduction,
right?
But if you started with that ketone and edited Methyl Grin Yar,
then the methyl doesn't have any hydrogen Beta that it could give in reduction.
So now you get a good yield of the product that you wanted.
So there,
so sometimes it's helpful to,
to choose one of the bonds to make.
So in making this,
in trying to make this alcohol,
the thing you get when you've protonate here,
you could make this bond or this bond or this bond,
but the bonds to methyl are much more practical to make them the bond to the ch
two,
because of the risk of reduction.
Okay.
Now the vinegar reaction we can zoom through because you all know that from lab,
I don't remember what base you used to make the videography agent.
Do you remember
sodium
hydroxide?
So that,
so you had,
you didn't have such a simple video.
A reagent is this one,
a notice that here you make the reagent by reacting with Bro,
by just light nitrogen would do an sn two reaction.
Now you have that cad ion and you treat it in this case with a very strong base,
butyl lithium,
right?
So a carbon and iron.
What's the Ph of a carbon hydrogen bond?
Typically just like butane losing a proton
order of 50,
right?
Very weak acid.
So the butyl lithium is a very strong base.
Okay.
And pulls that Proton off the ch two.
Now in this case,
the PKA is about 30 of that,
of the ch three group to lose a proton,
right?
You're never going to get that off with hydroxide,
Uh,
but you can do it in this,
in this case there,
uh,
with a stronger base.
But what is it that you couldn't do this if instead of phosphorus you had
nitrogen.
Now what's good about forming this an ion?
Why is that anti in a reasonable one to try to make where you don't pull
hydrogens off carbons willy nilly and not off normal hydrocarbons?
What does the neighboring phosphorus have to do with it?
How does it make it easy to form the anti it?
Well,
the phosphorus is a cat eye and it's easy to form an anti in near the cad I,
and you could do that with nitrogen and it could be an end plus the next
neighbor up in the periodic table,
right?
But phosphorus is even better,
Because when you get that and I,
and to be stabilized fos for us down in the next row of the periodic table has
vacant d orbitals that are able to stabilize that electron.
So it's a specially acidic but not so acidic that you're going to pull it off
with Oah minus.
Right?
So you could draw a resonance structure where you have a double bond where not
only the phosphorus has given electrons to the carbon in making the bond,
but the,
uh,
carbon has given electrons back to the phosphorous through this d orbital
interaction.
Anyhow,
you have this so called Iliad and then it can act as a nucleophile with the
carbon eel.
And now the,
the,
the uh,
oxygen can add to the phosphorus,
which can form five bonds because it has extra valence orbitals these d
orbitals,
right?
So you get the four membered ring,
but that very easily unzips uh,
because the po double bond is unusually stable.
The Eno bond of a,
of a trivalent nitrogen that in adds oxygen is only 70 kilocalories per mole,
but the phosphorus version is a hundred kilocalories per mole because of those d
orbitals making it especially stable.
Okay.
So you can get that try fennel phosphine oxide and the alkene.
And as you know,
what this Davidic reaction results in is replacing double bond o by double bond
ch two or in other cases,
double bonds.
See something else depending on what you started with up here.
Okay.
And I say directly because there are other ways of going round about to do this
rather than to do it directly.
For example,
you could add a methyl grin yard to this ketone to make the alcohol,
treat that with acid,
lose the water to make the primary cat died,
and it could then lose a proton and that would replace,
here's,
here's where our ch two is coming from,
right?
And then we lose the h from the ch three to get that.
So that replaces the double Bondo with double bond c h two the same thing.
The video reaction would do,
except that's not the major product.
It's a minor product.
What's the other product?
The other product is losing a different Alpha hydrogen,
right?
One of those.
That's the major product y it's a more stable owl keyed,
more highly substituted.
Right?
So,
so,
uh,
so you can see the advantage of the vintage reaction,
which directly gives the replacement of double bond o by double bond ch two in
this case,
or a double bond,
CHR or double bond cr two.
Now I was going to say a little bit about Green Chemistry and in connection with
some of these reactions we're talking about.
So pharmaceuticals are big chemical industry nowadays.
100 years ago it would still have been dye industry,
right?
And then petroleum,
pharmaceuticals,
plastics.
But now pharmaceuticals,
uh,
generate only 0.2% of the chemical industry product measured by mass,
but 25% of its value buy in money,
right?
Which means that it's worth doing a lot of work to on those to do a lot of
reactions in order to get these pharmaceuticals.
There's a lot of value added,
right?
But in the process of doing all of these manipulations,
the pharmaceutical industry generates more than 50% of the chemical waste,
right?
So the idea of green chemistry is to find new ways of doing things that won't
generate so much waste or will be safer,
for example.
Okay.
So there was a,
there,
there's a journal called green chemistry,
and in 2000,
they published a paper called Ky Green Chemistry research areas of perspective
from pharmaceutical manufacturers.
So representative of representatives of the biggest pharmaceutical companies,
Astrazeneca,
glaxosmithkline,
Lilly,
Pfizer,
Merck,
Schering plough,
which is now part of Merck,
uh,
got together to talk about what they saw as the places where you could make
advances to make chemistry,
uh,
more friendly to the environment and the people practicing it.
Uh,
and uh,
obviously from the,
from the perspective of,
of,
uh,
of the pharmaceutical industry,
right?
So this is gazing into a crystal ball,
And there's nothing as hard to predict is the future.
Right?
But at least these are their ideas and are people that have a great practical
interest in it,
not only in the sense of their things they want to happen,
but they're willing to give money to people to try to help make it happen,
to do research projects,
to try to develop new ways of doing it.
So they were trying to decide what they would most like to have.
And Th th th so it involved frequency of use.
If there's a reaction you hardly ever use,
you don't want to spend a lot of trouble on that one.
But if there's something that you use all the time that you could make better
than that's important.
So frequency of use,
how much volume is involved of the of this stuff.
If it's only a milligram,
who cares?
But if it's tons,
that's a big deal.
And of course safety is another one.
So one of the top priorities is solvents because that's what they use the most
of.
So,
and in something that wouldn't occur to the outsider probably is a very
important thing is to clean the,
they have these big reaction vessels and they have to clean them.
So that stuff that's left over from the previous reaction doesn't get into some
other drug.
So they have to be scrupulously cleaned.
And two thirds of the solvent they use is used in cleaning the reactors to make
sure that they're,
they're cleans.
But there might be other ways of doing it.
For example,
use water and an oxidizing agent like hydrogen peroxide maybe to do it.
So then now they're interested in,
in that is one of the big,
uh,
steps they could take or replacements for what are called,
a protech solvent.
So these are organic solvents.
They'll dissolve organic compounds,
but they also typically dissolved salts.
So you can have salts react with organic compounds in these solvents.
So ones like NMP there on the left and methyl Perala Dean or demethylate
sediment or dimethyl form amid are very heavily used solvents because you can
mix organic and,
and salt reagents in them,
right?
But the problem is that there,
that they're very difficult because they're miscible with water.
They're very hard to get out of the water at the end of the,
uh,
at the end of the day,
right?
So they're worried about polluting the water streams.
So they would like to get replacements for that.
Now you could wish for anything you could wish for $2 billion.
I'd like to have $2 billion.
Now I'm willing to split it with all you guys.
That doesn't mean it's going to happen,
right?
And so you can see a real problem with this.
The reason these solvent's are good is because they're organic and they're
miscible with water.
But the visibility with water is what makes them bad cause it's hard to get out
of the water again.
So,
uh,
I don't know what progress has been made on this,
but anyhow,
it's something that they would really like.
But then they thought of 13 processes that is not just solvent's but actual
reactions that need improving.
And they thought ones that they already use heavily and 14 they suggested new
processes that there isn't a good way to do now but would really be handy.
A few if you could do them.
And then they voted.
So there were six companies represented doing the voting and each of them could,
could cast five votes to choose among the 13 processes that need improving and
another five votes among the 14 processes that they would like to have
available.
So this is,
this is the perspective from the people who really do it,
about what would be useful to do.
So current processes that need reviewing,
all six of them voted that a way of doing a forming amids,
avoiding poor Adam economy reagents.
Now what that means is you're just trying to put this nitrogen onto a carboxylic
acid to make an a mid.
But if you use other reagents that have an enormous number of atoms in it,
then necessarily you're going to have an enormous amount of waste generated,
right?
But if you could do it with Adam economy,
so you have a minimum number of Adam's going in,
in order to hope know,
ideally would be just the element you want to have added to the molecule,
right?
For example,
a catalyst might allow you to do that where a stoic geometric reagents where you
have to add a whole mole of it wouldn't do it.
So then,
Ooh,
activation for nuclear Phillips substitution,
this is something we've talked about a lot.
You make the,
Ooh,
you protonate it,
you make it into an acid chloride,
you make it into a Tassa late with the leaving group.
But this is something that five of these industries still say as one of the most
important things to develop.
A better way of activating,
Ooh,
for nucleus substitution,
reduction of Amids,
the carbonyl group in amids without using high drives a,
so they say lithium aluminum hydride having likely way to 38 and four drives per
molecule has the highest high dry density.
So it's from the terms of Adam economy,
it's very good.
Uh,
it,
but it code generates an inorganic byproduct,
which is difficult to separate from the product and that makes this filtration
slow.
You'll lose product when you're trying to filter it,
get absorbed in this,
uh,
extra junk that's being made.
So they need something better than the available.
Hey,
a hydride reagents or to be able to do oxidation or EFP oxidation without using
a chlorinated solvent.
Four of them said that was a top priority and they noticed in,
in,
in connection with the oxidation that using the Ma,
the kinds of metals like chromium or osmium that we've talked about or are
manganese,
these are virtually been eliminated from pharmaceutical processes because small
amounts of these metals can be injurious to the health.
So the FDA requires that there be none in there.
So better is to use oxidation oxidizing agents that don't involve such metals
when you're making pharmaceuticals.
Okay.
Then safer and more environmentally friendly.
Mitsui,
Nobu reactions.
Now we're going to talk about the myths and overreaction next,
but three said that was important.
So it's worth knowing what the myths and Obu reaction is if they think it's so
important.
Friedel crafts reactions on unactivated systems,
we talked about,
uh,
substituents that we're activating or deactivating,
right?
But they'd like,
they're not good ways they say of doing their Friedel crafts reactions on
unactivated systems.
At least two of them said that.
And two of them said nitration was a problem.
Not because the reactions hard to do,
but because of the danger of explosion with nitric acid.
Hey,
and now,
how about the new process.